dominic lion is preparing for takeoff
the 46 year old base jumper leaps from
bridges buildings and cliffs in a moment
he and a friend from Germany will dive
into this valley in the Swiss Alps
how's the VA it's here doing well go
through here he says and then rappel
down there even before you get to the
jumping part this is not a sport for the
faint-hearted from here it's a seven
hundred metre drop lauterbrunnen tall
height and craggy cliffs make it the
place for base jump and Susie asks from
around the world this friend asks if
he's ready is it quitting before might
swing seconds before we jump we count
down from three he says that way we can
synchronize our jumps and by that point
your brain is already in Jump mode
upswing ready three two one
with their wingsuits they can speed
along the cliffs a camera strapped to
the helmet captures the action
the x is equal name the first second of
free fall is the ultimate feeling of
flight he says but many have paid for
that supreme adrenaline kick with their
lives base jumpers are killed and loud
opponent I'll every year some of its
residents now call this place Death
Valley
this time everything goes smoothly apart
from landing on someone's front lawn guy
is now we're really psyched he says door
he asked his friend if everything is
okay it was a good jump that's after
they pack up the two will go for a beer
okay it's out it's only later the domina
client tells us that his parachute
became tangled during the jump it would
have hurtled uncontrollably towards the
cliff if he hadn't reacted in time and
untangled the cord the incident was
captured on camera but he doesn't want
to release the images to the public on
the edge of the cliff the base jumpers
have set up a memorial for those killed
almost all of them were under 30
but the atmosphere is relaxed many
jumpers spend our whole summer here
around a thousand extreme sports
fanatics come to Lau to bone in every
year the cliffs are within easy reach in
addition BASE jumping is legal here
Dominic loin is packing his parachute
ready for the next jump so much alike
that we labor steer for people who do it
it's a way of life he says they travel
to the best jump point in Italy Norway
or here in the summer they live in their
camper vans or something they built
themselves it's a way of life at least
in the summer months what it is doesn't
Laden steer huh
dominic has organized his whole life
around his passion the German national
moved to lauterbrunnen six years ago so
he could jump as often as possible he
gives BASE jumping lessons and works in
a sports store to finance his hobby
that's mutiny though a few meters away
farmer Matthias fights herds his cows
back to the barn for milking it would be
a relaxing trip he says if it weren't
for all the tourists along the little it
used to be just the skiers who came in
winter now the tourist season lasts all
year round diane von fields is now long
gone and so says the first group drives
too fast and the other two slowly and
there's not much in between you never
know when a cow is suddenly about to
change direction well you can't drive
past too quickly and you can't stand
still either I'll mist and live home
Leslie paragliders base jumpers rock
climbers and tourists who simply love
Switzerland flocked to the valley every
summer that climbed the cliffs race
bikes down the mountains and jump off
rocks and out of helicopters with all
manner of flying tools small wonder then
that the Swiss Mountain Rescue Squad
responds to more calls here than
anywhere else Matthias floyd's has
little sympathy for the new trend in
extreme sports he'd like to see BASE
jumping banned altogether
first reflects adults apathy denying
sportdog the main problem is these new
sports he says mountain bike paths run
straight through the forest the base
jumpers fly too close to the cliffs and
disturb the wild goat that's a pity
games and I'm steinberg tester and what
they are you liked it on anything man
indeed now you can do it's all quite
upsetting ordinary walking is too boring
for these people let's go behind me it's
always got to be something crazy well
hey mrs. submitted oh they're not
another model the problem is the animals
can't get used to all this it's too much
too fast hablame vote on transit
defeated an alcoholic governess getting
him to Chanel that's all he wants to say
about it criticism of the extreme sport
tourists isn't welcome here in the
valley because they bring in money for
the local economy so Matia sports would
rather talk about his cows I grew up
with the animals he says they're like
family ines that hang of it sealed the
36 year old can't imagine selling the
family business for a job in tourism
all badly bells long boobs I love
working as a farmer he says I love being
close to nature and close to the animals
it's hard work but the animals give so
much back it's a good profession I can
clean this side up in the meantime
Dominic lion is showing his pupils
tassels Polycarp ooh how to properly
store a base-jumping parachute does
design study get a name of all his
embrace relies on meticulous preparation
for the jump he explains first and
foremost that means packing everything
the right way i can raise up the
parachute he says the risks of BASE
jumping can be minimized with proper
training and preparation he goes into
minut detail with BASE jumping beginners
every chord every crease is important
when folding the parachute but even the
teacher has had his share of dangerous
situations when the China
note i was losing from gym he says he
once had to pull on the emergency cord
so nobody but by the time the parachute
opened he'd practically hit the ground
doctor foo natassia got it in sheung
gosh that's Acharya sure ephrata luckily
he says nothing happened all stuff how
has some look nice but yet what do you
mean nothing happened if you practically
landed without a parachute I can only
show on all five it says he landed in
snow at a 45-degree angle like a ski
jumper woman fetish carving Google under
tea and conceived in chi springer but
he's almost never considered giving up
except maybe once yeah its caption
and Parker Duncan and upon science
hooligan I thought about taking a break
he says or giving it up all together
when a good friend of mine was killed
fighting from the tutelage phone but
then you come to terms with it I when I
thought I did mine done don't you
somehow you have to do what gives you
pleasure I don't respond some a student
you think about it and then you come to
the conclusion that you have to keep on
going and you swear you'll never make
the same mistakes on truth honesty like
and feel at salon
okay after the packing lesson it's off
to the exit what they call the jump spot
come on Frank in the butcher shop aided
gas has adjusted to the new clientele
she offers a range of sausages as the
ideal base jumper snack tourist we live
side by side with the tourists she says
you get used to having all these crazy
strange and friendly people around dick
on 7 and you get to know the whole world
that way No so you don't have to go
anywhere because they all come to you
get cold when y'all he'd head but to
jump from the cliffs herself that's
something she can't imagine doing it not
really she says you're taking your life
into your hands sustained box office to
me spiel MIT dem leben for me yeah
right there with tassels Polycarp ooh
and his jump instructor are once again
practicing the choreography of the
descent the 37-year old already has 20
base jumps under his belt but that makes
him just a beginner 8,000 9,000 10,000
touch pool and symmetric on the pole oh
good once he's on the cliff there's no
going back good job
three two morrow a leap of faith and
hopes for a smooth landing
you